well it seems like in the early eighties
the idea the whole idea was to find
yourself a label and be on it and it
seemed like we when I was in as any
group called the Del Fuegos and we all
we had one label that we wanted to be on
in those slash records that was where
the blasters and Los Lobos and X and
rank-and-file and the Violent Femmes
they were all on that label and we just
thought that's that was the that was
kind of the the more high-octane
American music and that's that's where
we ended up so there was a music
industry now I don't know I you know now
after making after making five records
for other labels I was completely
convinced that going when I started
doing the family music I I decided at
the very beginning that I would start my
own label because I had made five CDs
for other labels and didn't own anything
I had no rights to any of the music so
other than the music publishing so I
thought well that doesn't seem right
does it why don't I just start my own
label and now the technology has changed
and you can really do it this way so
it's and I think the music industry may
have killed itself in a way and but it
makes incredible opportunities for the
smaller smaller operations so my label
we've put out ten CDs and this is our
tenth year you know we've been going
we've been going really strong for for
ten years and figuring out alternative
ways to do it and I you know I couldn't
imagine I couldn't imagine what that I
would still be able to keep going if I
had signed with a label to do this
family music I don't think it would have
been I don't think anyone would have
hung in there for ten CDs it just
doesn't happen that way anymore
except for a handful of people but I
like to think that maybe I'm in the toy
industry rather than the music industry